en los últimos vídeos hemos escrito un
pequeño programa muy bonito que pide al
usuario que tecleo un número y luego
calcula el factorial de ese número y lo
imprime y eso está muy bien pero podrían
imaginarse un mundo en el que tuvieran
que calcular el factorial desde muchos
lugares desde muchos programas o que en
un mismo programa tuvieran que calcular
el factorial muchas veces no querrían
escribir ese código una y otra vez cada
que tuvieran que calcular el factorial
de un número así que lo que voy a hacer
en este vídeo es definir una función
para calcular el factorial de un número
y podremos usar esa función cada vez que
necesitemos saber un factorial entonces
esencialmente lo que voy a hacer es
poner este código en un lugar y luego
cada vez que un programa necesite
calcular el factorial de un número podrá
llamar este código en lugar de
reescribir lo y déjenme mostrarles lo
que estoy diciendo voy a definir una
función y la palabra clave en python es
una palabra especial que le dice el
intérprete que algo importante
pasar la palabra para definir una
función en python es de d
efe así que voy a definir una función
que llamaré la función factorial y es
una buena idea poder indicar mediante el
nombre de la función lo que esta función
hace algunas veces los programadores
principiantes ponen nombres como x 4 2 5
y cuando alguien viene no tiene idea ni
manera de saber a qué se refiere esa
variable o esa función
así que definan su función con un nombre
que dé una idea de lo que hace mi
función se llama factorial y cuando el
usuario llame a esta función factorial
será necesario que le indique el número
del que quiere calcular el factorial así
que voy a pasar un argumento lo voy a
llamar número esto puede resultar un
poco confuso pero lo explicaré en
detalle en un momento piensen que
mientras más vean esto más van a estar
familiarizados con estas ideas
y vamos a pasar un número y solo tengo
que regresar a la llamada del programa
el programa me pasa a un número para
calcular el factorial y yo tengo que
regresar el resultado tengo que regresar
el factorial al programa que llamo esta
función así que déjenme escribir un
comentario aquí en esta línea devuelve
el factorial del argumento número
algunas veces escucharán la palabra
parámetro y algunas veces escuchará la
palabra argumento cuando se hace la
definición de una función
esto es más formalmente llamado
parámetro número es uno de los
parámetros de la función factorial el
número real que alguien pasa a la
función digamos que alguien llama la
función factorial con un 3 aquí este 3
es más formalmente llamado argumento así
que devuelve el factorial del argumento
número y este es el argumento número y
no me estoy refiriendo a esto como la
palabra número sino como el argumento
número me refiero a este número de aquí
tal vez podría poner esto entre comillas
para que se entienda bien que este es el
argumento no estoy hablando de un número
en general y ahora voy a usar el mismo
código el que escribimos en los vídeos
anterior es esencialmente el mismo
código solo voy a copiar y pegar voy a
copiar y pegar esto todo esto que use
por acá lo voy a cortar de aquí y lo voy
a pegar de este lado
pero tengo que tener mucho cuidado con
la invitación porque es mediante la
implantación como python puede reconocer
que es parte de que así es como sabe
cómo interpretar el código todo lo que
es parte de esta función debe estar
intentado con cuatro espacios 1 2 3 4 y
aquí debe haber otros cuatro espacios 1
2 3 4 y esto es parte del ciclo for 1 2
3 4 y creo que es todo lo que tenemos
por aquí entonces vamos a pasar un
número
luego definimos esta variable producto
igual a 1 y hablaremos más sobre el
alcance de las variables pero esta
variable sólo la podemos usar en la
definición de esta función factorial
porque la primera vez que la definimos
está dentro de esta función ya
hablaremos más sobre el alcance de las
variables en el futuro y luego tenemos
la misma lógica que ya hemos visto antes
fort y range del número ahora no estamos
obteniendo el valor del número mediante
la función input
aunque se pasará a la función factorial
y luego producto es igual a producto por
1 es la misma lógica que teníamos antes
después de que pasamos por este ciclo
for cuando terminamos el ciclo fort y
pasaremos por este ciclo for el número
de veces igual a número o sea al valor
que contiene número entonces la variable
producto tendrá el valor del factorial
de número y en lugar de imprimirlo
directamente lo que vamos a hacer es
regresar return regresamos al programa
que llamó a la función factorial en el
siguiente vídeo voy a hacer un diagrama
para mostrar esto de una manera más
limpia por si esto es un poco confuso
para ustedes entonces voy a regresar al
producto así que esencialmente es el
mismo código que teníamos antes pero lo
empaquetar hemos dentro de una función
definimos una función en la que tenemos
un parámetro llamado número si ustedes
hacen factorial de un número digamos
factorial de 3
13 en el argumento lo que será puesto en
el lugar de la variable dicho de otra
manera lo que la variable número está
apuntando a lo que se está refiriendo
eso será el argumento definimos producto
igual a 1 luego vamos al ciclo for four
y en range de número esto lo explicamos
en el vídeo anterior todas las veces
empezando en 1 o mejor dicho en 0 luego
hacemos 1 por 1 producto es igual a 1 la
siguiente vez y es 1 y hacemos uno por
uno más uno o sea 1 por 2
entonces producto es 2 y seguimos
haciendo esto incrementando el valor de
y todo esto lo vimos en detalle en un
vídeo anterior y finalmente devolvemos
el valor del producto tenemos el mismo
comportamiento que ya habíamos visto
antes solo que ahora estamos usando esta
función y lo que podemos hacer es que
podemos seguir teniendo esta función
input
esta es la definición de nuestra función
entonces a lo largo de nuestro programa
principal pasamos por la definición de
la función y ahora decimos al usuario en
esta función input teclea un número
entero no negativo para calcular el
factorial y ponemos ese número en una
variable que llamaremos entrada del
usuario quitamos esta que teníamos aquí
y ponemos entrada del usuario y también
definiremos otra variable que llamaremos
factorial de la entrada del usuario
factorial de la entrada del usuario y
luego haremos algo interesante
llamaremos a esta función factorial
entonces hacemos factorial de la entrada
del usuario es igual a factorial estamos
llamando a la función factorial con esta
instrucción es igual a factorial a la
función factorial de la entrada del
usuario factorial de entrada del usuario
factorial de la variable que está aquí
la variable factorial de la entrada del
usuario estará almacenando o mejor dicho
estará apuntando a la respuesta al valor
del factorial de la entrada del usuario
y sólo nos queda mostrar el valor
podemos decir en primer factorial de la
entrada del usuario print factorial de
entrada del usuario y estas líneas
parecen instrucciones pero solamente son
nombres de variables estoy usando estos
nombres de variables para que sepan lo
que estas variables contienen o a lo que
se están refiriendo como lo mencionamos
al principio
ahora sí llegó el momento de la verdad
cuando salvamos el programa y tratamos
de correrlo trataré de correr este
programa para ver qué pasa
bueno parece que no hubo ningún error al
inicio quiero dejar claro esto el
programa empieza aquí pero lo que
hacemos en esta parte es definir la
función solamente definimos la función
no estamos creando ninguna interacción
con el usuario ni tampoco estamos
procesando nada todavía solo estamos
definiendo esta función después baja a
esta parte y dice ok aquí hay una
función input debemos pedir algo al
usuario y eso es lo que estamos haciendo
aquí después de que leemos un número del
usuario aquí entonces llamamos a la
función factorial con este número que el
usuario teclea otra vez el usuario
teclea un número y lo ponemos en la
variable entrada del usuario y llamamos
a la función factorial con la variable
entrada del usuario como argumento así
que trataremos de hacer esto con el
número tres tecla
el número 3 y oops no funcionó esto no
funcionó y ya vi por qué no funcionó
dejé esta línea aquí del programa
anterior y esta línea no viene el caso
en este programa dejen de borrarla esto
es una buena elección es raro que un
programa corra perfecto a la primera así
que déjenme intentarlo otra vez déjenme
tratar de correrlo otra vez 3 otra vez y
me devolvió la respuesta correcta 6 es
el factor y'all de 3 y lo que está padre
aquí es que el intérprete de payton está
asumiendo que esta definición ya está
hecha y podemos llamar a la función
factorial desde el intérprete y si
tuviera otro programa la podría llamar
de varias formas espero que puedan
apreciar lo bueno que es haber podido
definir una función porque ahora podemos
calcular el factorial de un número vamos
a calcular el factorial de 4 es 24 y
ahora podemos calcular el factorial de 5
- el factorial de 3
114 y también podemos hacer el factorial
de 12 este es el verdadero poder de las
funciones que no tenemos que reescribir
el código cada vez solo tenemos que
llamar a las funciones con diferentes
argumentos hagamos factorial de 2 lo
puedo hacer cada vez no tengo que volver
a correr el programa si escriba otros
programas que usen el factorial
probablemente podría usar esto como una
función de hecho no es necesario que el
usuario final sepa lo que está pasando
dentro de la función este es otro
aspecto poderoso de las funciones
digamos que escribo muchos programas que
llamen la función factorial y que
encontramos una mejor manera de escribir
esto que está aquí mientras que el
programa pueda obtener el resultado el
usuario final no lo notará probablemente
encontramos una forma más rápida o una
forma más simple que use menos memoria o
menos recursos de cpu para hacer esta
misma función
entonces reemplazamos el código y todo
seguirá funcionando bien